la mandataria peruana ha sido muy
enérgica hacia el parlamento ha señalado
que existen algunos congresistas que
están tratando de bloquear el adelanto
de elecciones y ella les ha llamado a la
conciencia les ha dicho que reflexionen
y que no se escuden en abstenciones y
que le den la cara al país Porque existe
el 83% de los peruanos Que quiere un
adelanto de elecciones la mandataria ha
hecho referencia a que ayer precisamente
49 legisladores votaron a favor treinta
y tres en contra de este proyecto y 25
se absorbieron de votar y para todo esto
se necesita señalan algunos
especialistas más de 270 días es
necesario que se presente un presupuesto
de lo que va a significar el gasto la
logística se llamen a elecciones
primarias a los partidos políticos y
también se adecue todo conjuntamente con
el organismo electoral y también con en
la registraduría pero más allá de todo
se necesita que partidos políticos
organizados se presenten en sus listas
pero no solamente eso sino que lo que se
reclama se quiere un cambio cambio de de
la clase política y algunos señalan que
adelantar todo sería nuevamente volver a
lo mismo Francisco contanos qué está
ocurriendo en las calles de Perú venimos
de jornadas de protestas
antigubernamentales que dejan ya 22
personas muertas
Así es justamente El Perú se encuentra
en un estado de emergencia nacional se
ha decretado toque de queda para algunas
provincias de ese país y ha estado
rindiendo sus frutos ya los militares
han desbloqueado algunas carreteras ya
no hay toma de aeropuertos pero la
protesta se ha traslado a otras regiones
como es la selva central en el caso de
la comunidad de quepacheato que provee
el gas de camisea hay manifestantes que
han tomado esta planta y están poniendo
en riesgo el abastecimiento de gas
natural algunas zonas del país y la
presidenta boluarte ha sido muy enérgica
con los manifestantes qué es lo que va a
ganar los manifestantes con tanta
violencia con tanto bloqueo de carretera
con toma de aeropuertos y sobre todo con
pérdida de Vidas la mandataria ha
llamado al diálogo a la población para
que retorne la tranquilidad al Perú